sh
hi good morning uh everyone and welcome
to what we believe is going to be a
promising uh event a panel discussion on
the topic of digitalization digital
health and Technology uh what we will
discuss in this session is how we can
foster a collaborative relationship
between the EU and India
for open interoperable and a secure
digital Health
ecosystem uh the digital transformation
in health is not just a matter of
technological change or technological
muscle it's more of an extensive socio
technical exercise where you've got
different cultures you've got uh policy
uh uh angle in it you've got politics in
it you've got economics and Innovation
and the intersection of all of these
that really will transform how we think
about digital Health in the future and
the EU given its commitment to
protecting patients rights and digital
protection laws and its Advanced Digital
Health framework along with India with
its rapidly ever growing digital
infrastructure and the tech savvy pool
that it has are I think uniquely
positioned to take on this Challenge and
lead the transformation on a global
scale so today we have a distinguished
panel of speakers and I will introduce
them uh in a while um the plan for the
session is that we have worked for a
while now on a report which was funded
by uh the EU India digital think tanks
initiative and uh the idea of the report
was to look at the possibilities of
collaboration between the EU and India
knowledge transfer and knowledge
exchange so for the first uh 10 minutes
we will have our Indian representative
present uh some brief findings of that
report and then we will delve into the
panel discussion so the panelists of
course you're curious to know who they
are uh we are very pleased to have uh
katalina movitz who will I will
introduce her a bit more when she joins
us on stage we have Dr jubin sha as well
who's based out of heidleberg we've got
Nita tagi who's joining us online uh KES
Sher who leads the dialogue um Kesh and
Nita will join us online and we've got
the founder of dialogue kazim rzvy as
well um along with me we have a second
moderator who is Pavan Anand and he will
introduce himself when he joins us so
kamish I'll hand it over to you now now
uh if you can hear me and we'll be very
happy to hear uh what you are presenting
about the findings we have from this
report and then we'll take on the
discussion from there
on yes we can yeah and we can see
you
y
yes we can
yeah
highlights like you know what are the
certain policy level and
implementational level um level concerns
that both the jurisdictions May face or
already facing and might need to like
give attention towards as we move
forward with like you know uh taking
forward these initiatives so the
objective of actually mapping the
constraint is to actually look where
like is there any ways like there's a
you know scope for Collaborative
Learning and knowledge exchange between
EU and India in terms of tackling those
issues
and um for instance it is like if I
could like give an instan is that like
EU has demonstrated a high level um you
know an advanced approach towards
policymaking and data related domains
while while as India has been like
finering and like championing scaling
Data Systems and making them
interoperable right so this is what the
background of the study has been and
like what we are tried to achieve one a
is like looking into the constraints and
what are the collaborative like
knowledge exchange that can happen
between you and India and like actually
solving those
constraints so um in in in in tandem to
whatever I said as the background to our
stud itself like the research question
has been like it's obviously the lessons
that India could learn from EU in
respect to the scope of data regulations
of electronic health records or digital
health records and like lessons that the
EU can learn from India in terms of like
you know National Health sta with
respect to scalability of the electronic
health records exchange particularly
like you know on the aspects of
interoperability then finally we also
looked into the boundary conditions for
en interaction between India and the
digital healthy systems so um the
methodology that we followed is like Pro
wrong approach a is secondary research
where we actually like try to use the
pestal analysis in terms of like um
getting down the boundary conditions for
what are the things that we have to like
you know achieve through this study and
like what are the mutual ways of like
exchanging could be and also we did a
met analytic literature review in terms
of like finding out what are the
existing literature available on the
space like where can our research come
and like you know fill in the Gap and um
and also we did the primary research
where we did some qualitative um
semi-structured interviews with the
representatives like um industry experts
data governance experts and like you
know international relations experts
members of the Civil Society and Pro
from both EU and India the digital
health facilities and other recipients
from Inu so like why we did this is like
we wanted to understand the multiple
view view points and concerns about
interoperability and privacy of the
digital L ecosystem in both the
jurisdictions in terms of like mapping
the constraints and also what what the
experts have to tell us about like what
are the key learnings that the Ved
jurisic and jurisdictions can actually
have um so moving on to that like from
there like you know um both the
countries uh first let me like you know
take you through the constraints faced
by EU and India within the digital
systems we actually know that both
countries use different
approaches when it comes to like you
know how we like handle or tackle the
digital health records right um but like
um but also like we wanted to like you
know point out what are the constraints
that they might face within the three
facets which is what like you know the
first facet that we looked into like
what are the constraints they face
within the data protection landscape so
one of the key um aspects which is like
within the you know at the India side
when it comes to con within data
protection landscape is that absence of
a legislative man mandate so here we
actually try to look into like um you
know how the abdm or the national um um
you know data Health data management
policy was formed so without a
comprehensive regulatory framework the
implementation process and
infrastructure actually acts as um you
know regulation and substituting or the
like the substituting or displacing the
Parliamentary laws right so while the
implementation process which is put out
by the you know the mission statement
and Etc and stuff does create like part
dependencies and fosters like
cooperation and structures however like
such Frameworks may not really bring
flexibility that one needs in terms of
like you know legal mandates to
establishing rights and like you know
delting responsibilities and providing
remedies so while there was an intention
for like a draft legislation to support
the abdm system it was expressed in 2019
we have not seen anything frutal at this
moment so moving on to the next
constraint is the lack of higher degree
protection to the Health Data so like we
all know that like you know India
recently passed the digital personal
data protection act 2023 which applies
uniformly to all the you know Healthcare
professionals providers facilitators and
Etc but there is no higher degree of um
um you know protection for the breach of
certain categories of personal data such
as health data which might actually have
a higher level of like you know greater
level of harm to the individual so um
having said that like I also want to
like make a cat here is that DP DP DP
DPA 2023 is not the only um legislation
available there um India India also like
has like um something called as the
sensitive personal data or information
rules which actually Cates for the
sensor personal data which is one of the
data the Health Data itself however
there's little bit of uncertainty at
this moment whether this like you know
rules will be absorbed within the you
know data protection regulation or or
not so then comes the compliance
constraint as like as as like the data
protection regulations is a new start
within India um there's like a long way
to go in terms of like you know how the
industry will comply to some of the you
know Universal principles that are
actually like prescribed to the
legislation itself this is basically
like you know though maybe the
internationally present organizations
might actually like have been little bit
acclimatized to this process but India
is a very rich country with ecosystem
which has like a lot of start s which
are working especially within the
digital Health ecosystem and like how
they will be like you know transitioning
towards this is a you know important
aspect and also at this moment like we
don't have a data protection regulator
so who might have been in help in terms
of like advising and providing like
guidelines and Etc and stuff which might
the government might do but like having
a regulator separately doing might have
been a little bit of a hell which is not
present at this moment so next comes the
rights and the duties of the data
principle this might be overarching but
this can also have implications within
the digital health um you know Paradigm
that we are talking about um like one
interesting aspect or like one one
aspect that the Indian government has
put within the legislation's duties for
data principles for raising you know um
their complaints and Etc and stuff
towards the board this might actually
like like have like um unintended
consequences like you know uh people
might be cautious in terms of like not
able to like um exercise their rights so
then moving on towards the European
Union itself the premises of the data
protection
regulation um is like almost mostly
within the you know Paradigm of like how
can we protect the right of privy but um
also like the other flip side of the
coin is that like you know how can we
actually unlock the value for the
benefits the citizens and Etc businesses
and communities have by using the data
which is like little bit not much like
deliberated though like EU isting on
this at this moment but GDP doesn't
really do much there and over the length
of the contra in fact there might be
like um you know also applicable to
India and others like as gdpr sets the
golden standards for mostly um you know
within the aspects like I guess like
this is something which we need to see
whether it's going to be available for
others and privacy and value thing is
something that the European um experts
have pointed out is that how the people
with Indian um individuals actually have
a mindset about like how privacy and
value of data is something that is like
you know too not sitting in tandem
whereas like they think that if they are
actually going to move towards
digitalization they might be trading of
their privacy um scalability constraints
like you know we looked into a couple of
aspects like infrastructure disparities
um where like you know one of the
aspects is that like India still moving
towards digitalization and like there is
also remote areas where it's not there
and um regulatory Frameworks is
basically we look into is that is there
are multiple regulatory framework that
they have to the you know digital Health
ecosystem has to operate and this could
bring a lot of like confusions and STI
Innovations Healthcare Workforce
training is basically as I mentioned
Works in tandem with the digitalization
efforts where like still Health
Healthcare professionals Etc are not
very much like acclimatized towards
using digital services financial
constraint is again like you know
understanding whether there is an
importance towards like having any
funding requirements for the
digitalization um EU level like
fragmented healthcare system which is
basically like member states have like
different Healthcare systems and as well
as like follow different from you know
formats and that can actually cause
concerns and again like regulatory
complexity is like a similar aspect that
we looked into in terms of how member
states keep on like you know handle
these things and like you know and how
this is going to interoperate and
resource allocation is something that we
look again which might be near to the
financial constraints aspect that the
India faed like how can we actually like
look you know towards like making a case
for like digitalization within the you
know Healthcare System and resistance of
change this second with the point that
we mentioned earlier in terms of like
the tradeoff between like you know
privacy and digitalization and also like
there's a little bit of you know experts
have pointed out there resistance
towards Bing
digitalization um interoperability
concerns that we quickly I wanted to
like cover here is the lack of vertical
regulatory interoperability within India
where we have multiple digital laws
coming into picture and not interacting
with each other and lack of Center State
interoperability basically here we talk
about is that is you know there is no
in India like you know the health health
as a subject Falls within the states and
States already have a lot of like you
know um their systems and um data
management processes and we don't know
really how this is going to interact and
interoperate at this moment time and at
the EU level lack of foundational and
semantic interoperability at the private
level because first at the private level
because like the private sectors within
like different member states work
differently and follow different systems
and this can bring like interop concerns
especially at the foundation and
semantic level I at the national level
like you know the Public Health Systems
also follow like different different
systems different aspects which can
bring interoperability con kamish can I
interrupt you there um you have about
two to three minutes to wrap up so it
I'm concluding I just have like couple
of like you know slides I'm concluding
thanks thanks Mah yeah so coming quickly
into the recommendations part itself
that we are like talking about is that
the three key recommendations that we
were able to get from EU learning is
like extended additional protection to
the health health data where like we try
to like look at like India's
jurisprudence on data protection is just
evolving and like while has done a lot
of work in terms of like how they proted
the digital health and like you know
records and Health Data and Etc so how
can we learn from there is something
that the report looked into and then we
move on towards the regulatory
interoperability to enhancing the
ecosystem so here we looked into how the
center State regulation Center State
interoperability can work where like you
also operates in similar kind of
approach um then we moved on towards
like evaluating the performance of the
data protection regulation as I
mentioned India's just moved into it
whereas like gdpr um has been doing this
for some time and like you know there
has been constraints which has been
faced over the time but like how we can
actually systemize this process from the
learning from India some EU is something
that we actually like you know looked in
our paper for India um moving moving on
like you know to the recommendations for
EU laying the road map through the
public infrastructure as we know India P
the digital public infrastructure
Frameworks and um you know what are the
key learnings that the you know the EU
can actually have in terms of adopting
certainly some of the aspects at the
infrastructure level for bringing
interoperability importance of dig LP
system and the digital identification
system basically it's one of the facets
of the digital public infrastructure and
how that is important to have a
functional and foundational ID is
something that we looked um at the EU
level by adopting some learnings from
India and and enhancing um you know
scalability using ecosystem approach one
important aspect here is that um you
know the um we looked at is that it's
like various e within the ecosystem in
India there are various players within
the system they all come and work in
Tandem and like how can you can learn
from that is also be looked and
principal level is simple as that is
that there is a principal level you know
um um uh interoperability laid down to
the abdm blueprint and like how that can
be adopted and balancing the data
protection and creation which is from
India where we try to look at like
techno legal Solutions like you know
consern management and cons manager
Frameworks and Federated architecture
and Etc and stuff so and how can EU
learn from that so quickly one minute
like you know final thing like how we
actually wanted to like you know
envisage the digital Health interaction
between you and India we actually looked
upon like one of the key aspects which
is important for making this interaction
happen is interoperability between the
you know data protection regulations so
while both the jurisdictions are looking
at you know the data protection aspect
itself in a different format and like
different ways but there is a you know
underlining through our analysis we were
able to figure out there is underlyingly
some of the principles followed by both
the you know jurisdictions are similar
so this can be actually you know opening
conversation for both of the you know um
um jurisdictions in terms of like
actually enabling an interoperability
between or interaction between the
digital Health ecosystem between India
and EU so just I rushed a little bit
more but like the study is very
extensive so this is what we did and um
I can go in detail during the q& right
thank you so much thank you kamesh um
thank you for this uh brief summary of
the report it's an extensive report that
we've uh written over the last uh couple
of months and it is not published yet
but it will be uh published soon so you
can watch out for that and you can
follow us on LinkedIn and Twitter and
whatnot because we will announce uh the
publication over there um it's it is my
pleasure now to introduce the panelists
that we have for today's discussion so
to start with we have kolina um makix
I'm pronouncing that right yeah uh
kolina is the Innovation director at the
European connected Health Alliance and a
digital and public health consultant she
has over 14 years of professional
experience in international projects
with International organizations like uh
the who the oecd the World Bank and
other key Regional and National
stakeholders welcome kolina can you
please join us on the stage
our second speaker is uh Dr jubin sha
who is a product manager at kinomic
group uh he specializes in leveraging
clinical data for strategic decision
making and Healthcare his work focuses
on product management uh for new
products that are part of the company's
data and AI strategy uh he is also an
alumnist of heidleberg University and
has degrees in biotechnology life
sciences and bioinformatics jubin is a
strong advocate of Inderman bilateral
relations and creating a sustainable
strategic partner parip between the two
so very happy to have you here Jin can
you please join
us we have two of them joining online so
Nagi is an expert at the intersection of
technology and societal programs
particularly in governance and
Healthcare she Champions the use of
digital platforms and collaborative
efforts involving Society governments
and markets to tackle complex societal
challenges on a large scale so she works
with several uh Central and state
governments she has over 29 years of
experience at uh Global organizations in
diverse areas and she's been working on
this uh topic specifically on national
scale digital transformation for for the
past decade now so it is a pleasure to
engage with you today Nita thank you for
joining
us um we were just introduced uh uh to
Kesh uh Kesh leads the privacy and data
governance vertical and the AI vertical
at the dialogue the dialogue is um a
prominent think tank in India and has
been recognized by the University of
Pennsylvania as one of the top 10 Global
think tanks to watch out for um there is
naturally a big team of researchers the
founder is kazim rzvy who's a lawyer uh
in India and is a prominent figure in
India's public policy Arena so Kesh is
representing the dialogue today um he is
a youth Ambassador at the internet
society and holds a degree in public
policy from takshashila institution and
other degrees from the Tata Institute of
social social sciences so thank you for
joining us uh today Kesh and thank you
again for presenting the report finally
I will also introduce you to our lead
moderator today who is Pavan Anand he's
the founder of PES but maybe Pavan you
can give a brief introduction of
yourself and we can start with the
discussion
yeah
youone
okay um thank you so much everyone hi my
name is Pavan um I'm the founder of pra
um we are an innovation consultancy
based in India um and primarily we look
into supporting you know the access
adoption and documentation of um you
know new Innovations emerging Trends in
healthcare um and so This research that
we um collaborated with uh our partners
in India the dialogue as well as our
partners in EU um herty school um is I
think at a very topical and opportune
time as the world is also moving towards
um you know trending towards um getting
the healthcare digitalized um and uh
going towards the goal of um you know
universal healthcare coverage so um
maybe as I start um you know the the
panel um uh the first question that I
would really ask the panelists is um you
know a much more open-ended um broad
question um which is really around you
know is digitalization the next big
thing in healthcare and and how has it
contributed towards the goal of
universal healthcare coverage um Equity
as well as creating wealth and um you
know the one of the intentions to ask
this question is as well around you know
as EU India and other geographies around
the world grapple with making
investments into digitalization you know
how do they look at the return on
investment how do they also look at
making sure digital initiatives are
going towards um UHC and uh bringing
equity in healthcare
um maybe if it's okay I'll start with
you juin and then we can go to karolina
and Nita hi uh thank you so much for the
kind invitation and it's wonderful to be
part of this uh great panel um people
with so much experience I thank you for
the invitation again maybe uh just a
quick point on what you tried initiating
so if I look at the big picture and the
title of the discussion today which is
digitalizing Healthcare so so I've been
discussing this topic at least in my
career for Last 5 Years and I know
people who have been discussing this
over last 10 15 years and I'm pretty
sure that you would also hear that so we
we have been discussing that but where
are we right now so if I look at the big
picture and why this discussion is
important so if I just rotate the map
and see which are the regions in the
world which are stable uh which at the
political level at the cultural level at
the financial level I'm pretty sure you
would Define European region or the EU
and India as top two regions in the
world who would come together in why
there should be a strong collaboration
in healthcare just to add to that I you
see a lot of migration between the two
regions and that adds value why we need
further collaboration on that the second
point I also wanted to make uh towards
the big picture would be the patient
perspective so I'll just give you an
example yesterday I I got a minor
fracture I went to Orthopedic uh uh
doctor and he took an x-ray and he also
recommended me to go to a specialist but
he gave it in he gave the files in a CD
and asked me to take it to another
doctor I mean we are living in 2023 and
we are transferring the data through CD
uh and that took at least couple of
hours of time in the whole process and
similar example where I have a relative
had to get an MRI done it took one month
to transfer the data from one doctor to
another so where are we discussing and
where are we in the implementation I
think those are the two key points and
how it really impacts the patient
themselves is something which we need to
really discuss about yes you would have
people from the from the stakeholder
side but how it how it really impacts
the patient is something which we really
need to understand and that's where we
we would be able to understand how it
gives Roi or the value itself in terms
of the health outcomes maybe we can
definitely go further into
that well I'm thinking about this
question and of course I think we could
discuss it for a week there is so many
things to unpack and now thinking about
the patient perspective I think we all
have those uh those stories but maybe
still trying to to look at this from the
from the big picture you ask if the
digitalization is is the next think in
healthcare and um well I think think the
obvious answer is yes I think the the
obvious answer is there is no other way
and for many many reasons one of the
reasons I think what we experience in
the everywhere in the EU and I think
also elsewhere is the lack of resources
in the healthare and at the same time
increasing needs of the population when
it comes to the healthcare system and of
course there is number of statistics and
we've heard about this during coid times
that of course there is this Healthcare
debt that we will have to pay back we're
paying it back at the same time of
course the the population is getting
older not only in the EU it's like one
in many countries onethird of the
population is already older but also I
know that India is like going into the
same direction in in couple of years in
couple of Decades of course you are also
um India is also there so we have uh and
in many countries I I come from Poland
but I live in Finland and for many years
Finland was considered the best health
care system in the world but it's not
anymore it's actually the the the system
is at the brink of collapse because the
of the lack of the doctors in public
sector so the public sector has to buy
the doctor's time from the private
sector which is completely um uh Twisted
but that's another story as well so the
of course we need digitalization but not
only for for the sake of the optimizing
the resources that we can have robots we
can have ai um uh we can have like
solving or or covering the different
services that we actually don't need the
specialist knowledge by the by the
technology but we also have the of
course the issue of distances that's the
same I think in in India and it's the
same in in Europe of course when we are
in the city of Berlin maybe we don't
think about distances but then again
living in the northern Europe and there
is a lot of um a lot of communities
being far away from the specialist um
Health um facilities so this is also
something where we we can see the the
opportunity and aging I already mention
but again like what was said
implementation matters uh my mom used to
work in a hospital and when you will
speak with her about the digitalization
of the or bringing the new systems she
is just getting like oh my God don't
tell me about this because in her career
she had to deal every year I think with
different system being implemented but
those system never like collaborated so
it means that instead of writing one
paper for a paent the discharge letter
and maybe Cliff she had to like put
those documents into five different
datab bases one for the insurer one for
the employer one for the patient record
system and so on so forth so we really
have to think about it that it's not
only about bringing more technology to
the system but actually making sure that
people use this technology for better uh
outcomes thank you so much um I think as
you kind of talk a bit about the you
know digital digitization in healthcare
and how India is doing I would also like
you to maybe resonate on some of
Carolina's points really you know um uh
the doctor's availability also around
you know these different systems you
know because I know India is grapping
with a lot of challenges with you know
bringing insurance and EHR electronic
health records you know and making them
communicate so if you would also uh be
open to you know sharing some
perspectives of
that thank you very much um such a
pleasure to be here uh with my
distinguished panelists and thank you
for one um for inviting me I I found
myself smiling broadly when Carolina was
sharing the experience of her mom
because I I think that's what really it
is I mean and again I agree with her
probably there is no other way right
than to go through the digitization of
it but I have often wondered so my
journey in health started 2017 right and
it was basically working on what we now
know as National Health stack but at
that point point in time the problem we
were trying to solve was very different
it was about what India should do as a
you know a digital strategy I I'll be
I'll come back to that but I think I
just wanted to uh i' I've thought hard
about it often and like why hasn't this
taken off even though we feel that this
is the way to go why haven't we it taken
off and it is I think one it takes a
very deep understanding of the
incentives uh you know which are there
and at this point in time they are
actually ad adverse incentives if you
may call right and I think the other
thing
is the articulation of the benefits of
digital health I think that is missing
the measurement of it and the
articulation of it so I remember writing
an article uh you
know once after attending a conference
and I found myself saying that it is not
technology it is not policy that will
fail uh you know digital Health but it
is actually the articulation and the
measurement of when we say that these
are the benefits the ROI you started
with I think talking about foran so I
think that is one now I just wanted to
highlight uh you know one of the things
or maybe I can share my experience just
like Carolina said you know in 2017 I
was looking at um the launch of non
communicable disease Health tech systems
for Ministry of Health together with uh
you know two NOS uh one Tata trust as an
NGO and then corporate you know D EMC
and my interaction with Ministry
actually saw that the silos which are
there in the ministry right and how
these silos actually travel down they
put percolate down to the Frontline
workers so you know when we wanted to
launch this um app or this health Tech
system now obviously the users are the
Frontline people I had no single source
of Truth to actually get hold of this
data so if you can imagine there are 21
silos in the ministry each one is having
their own copy so that tells you right I
mean there is no single source of Truth
these are just databases these are not
live Registries which tell you who is
alive who's dead who's there who has
moved right so all those you know
problems start happening now when you go
on the on the ground you find these um
Frontline workers they're grappling with
I think like exactly what you said
Carolina right they had some 20 apps
even if they had one uh you know tablet
on each one of them they have to log in
separately uh you know and collect maybe
the same same data that 20 times right
so what happens is they become like a
the you know uh generators of data all
you know there in parallel silos again
and it really is not funny because they
are over fatigued they are
underpaid obviously and they don't get
access to the data which is actually
collected for some kind of decisioning
right how does it go back to them to be
able to do their primary work which is
to look after the
patients right
so I'll stop here probably I'm you know
over stretching my time there's so much
to say but I totally agree with what is
being said here yeah know I think very
very valid point Sita in fact I I I I
recall uh when I was doing some field
visits to some Primary Health Center
centers um in up and Bihar I mean they
the Frontline health workers who are
your auxiliary nurse midwives the um
social health workers ashas um they end
up I think spending couple of hours a
day just a they'll probably have to do
it on a paper and Pen first because
they're going to these remote areas and
then there's the expectation you know oh
you got to upload it and at the end of
the day they don't know why they are
uploading it and what are they going to
get out of it right so there's in a lot
of ways it's like you know why am I
collecting the data for the sake of
collecting the data right um I think
kamish if would love to you know also uh
hear your perspectives and add on to
this and perhaps also maybe you can um
touch a little bit upon you know the
secondary use um of Health Data um and
you know I would also like to maybe
Circle back to the other um panelists um
for their perspective on that as
well um thanks for like um yeah I I
think like you know everything is
mentioned already by Nita and like
kolina in terms of like you know what's
the state and um especially like you
know one point that also like bringing
back a study itself is that looks into
is the regulatory inter operat abilities
and like you know the silos that they
you know work within which actually
could like increase the you know the
burden at the you know Last Mile as well
as like you know might actually stiffle
the Innovations that are happening so
coming back like coming to the secondary
aspect itself is like I think like
that's one of the aspects that the EU is
like very much um you know looking into
through their EU he data space in terms
of like you know how can we use the
secondary um kind of like aggregated
level you know data usage so um there
again like I want to like Circle back on
like one more Point um in terms of like
um the constraints which actually happen
happens um at the level of two um one
again like circling back on the same
aspect of the regulatory Frameworks
because like uh why am I coming back to
the same point is that like sometimes
like you know when the Ministries are
not talking with each other which is the
case within Indian Juris Prudence um you
know the the flation of like the
secondary us usage of the data which is
like aggregating the data as like naita
pointed out like you're for forming like
10 20 forms and like maybe in all those
1020 forms like there might be some
unique aspects which actually are also
you like you know the Mandan aspects
also but like you know when those forms
are not talking with each other because
like one Ministry to the other is like
not talking to each other like you know
that that there is where like I guess
like the problem in terms of uh bringing
the systems together itself is like a
you know concern so most of the times
when we talk about like bringing the
systems we are mostly like concerned
with the you know the technicality
aspect and like you know other you know
operational infrastructural aspects but
like regulatory angle is very important
another is the resource constraints
itself right like in terms of like you
know as juban you know mentioned like
most of the times like many of these
data points that we want for the
secondary use are not even in form form
of like digital so you know like I guess
like there's also a resource and
infrastructural constraints which comes
in terms of like how we actually convert
such you know information towards you
know moving towards the digital platform
aspect itself right like you know if you
go to the remote areas within India or
Etc we will not really find such
infrastructures available for one to
like have their information fed within
the system so I'll just stop there and
like you know would love to come in yeah
sure sure thank you thank you so much
kames um karolina and jubin um um would
you like to add you know something on
the secondary use of Health Data um and
you know how has you know what's kind of
EU working on that um and you know where
do you see you know scope of
collaboration right maybe I will I will
comment on this I also want to comment
on the on the breaking the silos uh the
need for breaking the silos is something
that Nita also raised of course about
the secondary uh use of of Health Data I
think that this is again the thing that
we all understand that is very much
needed because there is so much data uh
collected gathered and and processed and
and finding the way how to really
distill the data and use it
for one thing is of course for for
better diagnostic but the other thing is
of course for prevention and the
decision making on the healthcare
policies but I think again um the the
the the issue here is like how we are
really like how will we implement it how
we will really make sure that those
systems are not only technologically and
legally perfect but they also are user
friendly I'm really excited about the
European health data space this should
be this regulation should be now voted
in the first half of November hopefully
so meaning like any day now um but I'm
also like scratching my head thinking
like how we are really going to do it I
was um last year at the at the meeting
in in Spain and there was a colleague
from Catalonia and saying guys we have
like 500 600 different systems that the
data sources in the hospital how we're
going to really like make sure that uh
that this is interoperable and really
brings the value to the to the whole
system but I'm sure that one way or
another we will find find a way of
course there is so many different
projects initiatives uh going on um but
maybe linking this to this need to break
silos and and I think that definitely we
we need to do it because it's like even
if we stay like okay there are
technology developers then there is
legislators then there is hospitals I
think we we need to like make sure that
really this whole ecosystem works
together this is also what something
that my organization the E Alliance is
doing that we bring together those
stakeholders that sometimes they don't
even know that they exist and they work
at they can work in one region one city
One hospital and then they meet at our
event on or online or in person and
they're like oh really do work on this I
I didn't know that you exist I didn't
know that you have this project in your
department so this is really something
that I think if you for example would
ask me like what would be this one small
step that we all can take is actually
this be curious and and like try to know
what the the other departments the other
sectors are doing and learn a little bit
um how this looks from the other
perspective I'm not a technologist for
me sometimes listening to the whole
architecture it's just like very
difficult but at least I try to be part
of this discussion to to also bring the
more social and more policy um um
perspective yeah great uh juven yeah I
was just trying to gather my thought on
on the topic I again it's an very
interesting and important question uh
because I focus on product side so I
always think from a patient or a user
perspective I was part of a panel
discussion few years ago where we had
patients again from a patient
perspective from India and a patient
perspective from Germany also
representing EU and we had a question
where okay what would be more important
uh access to technology and care where
okay the regulatory or the technology
itself is not fully compliant with
regulation and another topic was should
it be fully compliant and not not be
accessible at all and the answers we got
were very interesting the the patient
perspective from the the Germany or the
European region was okay we are okay if
we don't get access to the technology or
the final care but we would like the
consent and the compliance to be made
sure that it has to cater to the
regulations and on the other hand when
we heard the the same view from the
patient perspective from India uh the
the context was we need access because
we don't want to die the final end point
is okay we don't want death we want
access um for us it's okay if the
consent is managed somehow or if the the
whole compliance is managed in the
process or or it it would cater to at
some point so this is something which is
an important point also in the context
of secondary use maybe just to add to
the topic of interoperability again
because I focus on the product I would
like to take you to the the social
context let's say if there are uh and
three different set of examples where a
person from a rural region from India
who comes to Germany without knowledge
of German without knowledge of
technology and uh goes to let's say East
Germany some rural region and there you
meet a person who does not know use
technology and does not speak English so
how do those two people interact and you
have many systems within European region
or even in India who do not talk to each
other in this context so that's first
scenario the second is where you have a
person let's say coming from a midsize
City from India who knows English a bit
and he meets he or she meets a person
from Germany who also knows English a
bit and they're able to talk a bit and
there is some exchange of information so
the the second category is that kind of
systems where you have some exchange of
information happening the third is the
one where we would like to push it where
okay you have a person who speaks a bit
of German coming from India you have a
person person from Germany who speaks
well fluent English or at least
understands English and they're able to
communicate each other although not in
the same language but you have an
interface through the use of Technology
where the exchange is happening and this
the issue right now is we are still
stuck with the first and the second
level and we are not able to move to the
third level and that is what we we would
like to move towards or push towards and
then comes the context of the secondary
use of the data so even for example our
company we we work on the use or
developing a platform where we could
Leverage The the clinical data from
retrospective Manner and helped
organizations to use it for the
secondary purpose there are regulations
there are technology aspect but how do
you cater to pushing the the attitude of
utilizing it is something the the core
of the whole issue at least that's my
perspective uh but yes definitely there
would be added layers which should be
playing its own part wonderful yeah so I
think I think I've I mean I've heard a
lot about you know the the importance of
um you know being you know making
systems that talk to each other that are
interoperable um and you know where you
have some common fields um so you know
that really activates and amplifies um
the secondary use of Health Data you
know for um driving decision making um
you know predictive modeling and so on
um I I want to come back to the whole
you know know the regulations around the
interoperability framework as well as
you know the data security around it but
maybe you know I want to switch gears
slightly to go to you know um what is
like why are we all all here right which
is you know collaboration and one of the
key themes of our paper is you know um
how can these two you know vast
geographies jurisdiction the European
Union and India um how can they
collaborate well firstly you know taking
a step back um is there a scope of
collaboration um uh between these two
two geographies and at what level um and
maybe I'll go to you naita um uh and uh
while you kind of ponder over this
question um because you were involved in
the you know the the original you know
National digital Health blueprint um in
India back in you know 2017 and you know
you were kind of one of the key people
who built the framework and the policy
around you know ndhp which has now you
know been aishman digital Mission when
you were uh working on that um did you
you know kind of look at references like
Global references of digital Health uh
blueprints ecosystems um you know did
you look at some uh countries in the
European Union and you know what were
some of your inspiration as well um
maybe if you could touch a little bit on
that as
well thank you uh pan for that question
uh
because this research is something that
I started my baptism
sort of into into this field uh we did a
lot of research uh basically the idea
was to kind of see what works what
doesn't etc
etc but I think the if I have to
encapsulate my sort of um learnings from
that research it was
that India is very different to any
other country right um
and therefore our approach has to be
very different I think this was very
clear at that point in time we didn't
know what the approach is but we knew
that it is not something that we can
copy and paste from any other country uh
leave alone other things the size of it
so even if you know so so basically you
know there are three things that are
required in healthare uh affordability
accessibility and acceptability and
first my research kind of pointed out
there is not a single country which has
got the balance between the three even
if there is the size is incomparable to
what you know India has second I think
the problem biggest um uh differentiator
is that in India uh however little the
government spends so you would have
heard some controversial figures but
which don't go very far 1.2 to 1.8 to 2%
of GDP you know people keep asking
arguing about that India spends so less
and I find myself saying that hey even
if it were made to 5% that money will
not be spent because even this minuscule
amount is not being
spent and why is it not being spent
because there are frictions to this
money being spent right and you get the
point right so the government is
basically uh saying to half a billion
people that hey I'm here here to pay for
you but this service has to be provided
through service providers and then you
need the insurance providers right so
this whole uh lack of trust between each
other which increases the cost of any
claim that is you know that that goes
for um you know from a service provider
to an insurance it's almost like uh 800
rupees almost like I don't know is it
$20 or you know something like 15 to
$20 and when we talk of Indian healthare
we are striving for Universal Health
Care which means ipd as well as OPD how
can a
$1 OPD right we can hope to get that
passed by our insurance I mean they will
die even today they're just sort of
about there if you see in Insurance
health is not out of choice that it is
is offered right so I think that's the
biggest difference that the strategy and
that was basically unfolded through what
we call National Health stack
basically it gave a direction for how
even that money can be spent how trust
can be enhanced how these frictions can
be reduced and obviously digitization is
the answer to that you know so I'll stop
here but um that's the biggest learning
as we are looking at the collaborative I
think we also need to understand what
are the differences because then we can
go down the right path great thank thank
you so much Nita I think over to you
karolina same question um but I would
also like um if you can perhaps Ponder
on you know what the some of the uh
recommendations and insights um that
Kesh presented earlier right and uh you
know maybe specifically around you know
some recommendations that we have uh
highlighted um that you know India can
learn learned from EU and uh you know
maybe your perspectives you know you've
kind of you know from Finland or from
Poland but living in Finland so you have
I think a good handle on the whole you
know jurisdiction you know European
Union different countries right um and
the policies over there so I think maybe
you know something that we can learn um
and your perspective again a massive
question and and of course I think by
now you you you know probably that I'm
I'm a like a fan of collaboration I
think that this is something again out
of question we need to meet we need to
learn from each other we need to be
curious and actually I wanted to
congratulate you on this report you've
heard that the report is not published
yet but I was one of the lucky ones to
have a chance to to read it and was
really eye openening I I learned so much
about India from from this report uh we
as the organization we have some
collaboration with India and under our
Global health Connector partnership we
also facilitate the collaboration ation
between the European organization Indian
African Northern American and so on uh
my my colleagues have travel to India
for the events and and we have this
exchange so some understanding was there
where we can collaborate and what's the
opportunity of course business
opportunity learning opportunity but
this report again was uh I I hope it
will be published soon and I can
disseminated to to to my colleagues you
asked me if I can refer to some uh
recommendations what India can learn
from uh from you but I actually wanted
to pick on something that you
recommended to the EU or I don't know if
that was recommendation but that was one
of those um challenges or barriers I
think that was this cultural issue of
the resistance to change and I think
that this is also something that uh Nita
Nita raised and and also you raised with
this constant issue like are we really
like do we want to be legally ideal and
then perfect or are we allowing ourself
a bit of flexibility to uh to take the
to embrace the the the benefits to get
the best out of the of the system and I
believe that we have technology we have
legislation so it's really in the like
in the mindset to to to change and to
feel a bit more relaxed I of course I I
believe also in the in the power of
legislation so it's uh just to to to be
clear about that so I I think that this
is very good that you also pointed this
out I hope that as you said like also
the European officials will read their
report and and I hope that actually this
will become a bigger uh bigger thing
because I think that it's really I also
I also believe in the in the systemic
change so it's not only that you bring
again technology legislation but you
need to work with the with the health
system and it's very easy to take the
boxes to uh to just say we we reach this
target we reach this target but then you
see that nothing is changing in the
system so I hope that we can we can
actually learn uh learn uh learn that
and what you can learn from you I think
I leave it to you too to but I I think
it's it's also great to see that we can
really learn from each other and and
India is such a big country and there is
I think one thing that I also uh heard
on one of the sessions was that in India
the scale is so big that it's not about
Pilots everything is just implemented
while in EU we are a bit like in this
disease of the you know we we love to
have pilots and the EU finan lots of
pilots and the pilots are done and the
data is collected and evaluated and then
the project ends because the funding
ends right and then there and then we
have a project how to scale Innovations
and then the project does the pilots and
then it ends and so on so we are within
this vicious circle of the of the
piloting so I I I like this approach
that's like let's go we can always stop
we can always
pivot yeah no I think great point in
fact um um since we I think you know
started um the digitization of health
records and you know the abdm program um
it's it's it I think galloped right from
the start and you know more recently in
the last year or two you know there's
been a bit of you know hey let's just
step back and look at how it's going um
and more recently actually the
government has started this initiative
called micro sites
um where they are looking at you know
okay let's focus on um one city to begin
with so I know that it's been started in
like Mumbai in Gandhi nagar which is
another city in Gujarat you know where
it's like a few million people and let's
get all health professionals and uh
people uh you know with the health ID
registered on the health professional
registry so I think you know we are also
having uh to take you know step backs
you know look at okay let's try this I
think this is going to we're going to
learn a lot from it we're going to get
the impetus and then you know this micro
site can be taken all across the country
um I do definitely want to get um a
little bit deeper into the data security
and privacy angle I know um mujahid has
a couple of questions but maybe before
we go to that juban um uh just a quick
two minute as well you know on your work
in the EU India collaboration I know
you're also part of the the German India
um AI um bilateral Forum um you know how
do you see this collaboration playing
out and you know what's been your
experience as well yeah again an
interesting question may maybe just to
quickly also go back onto the your
question about what can India learn from
EU I think one of the points is and
again this comes from my personal
interactions with uh a lot of
stakeholders either from the the patient
side or from the companies or from the
uh regulatory side the the aspect is if
you have a data breach for example in
India in today's time how do you address
it and if the the person whose data has
been breached how can the person go to a
body or a a a council where they can
register a complaint and how quickly
that would be addressed there is a
provision within EU to do that and it is
addressed within a particular time frame
but that is something which I I feel
should be addressed within the Indian in
context now coming to your point about
the collaboration aspect when I went to
the European Union website I noticed
there are only two types of personal
data which are allowed to be shared
outside of you EU one is on the the
passenger list and the second is on the
the terror list so that that goes in a
very different direction but I was very
surprised that there is no discussion
on can there be a provision where even
the health health records or the
information on health is exchange
outside of EU and especially with
countries like India where the for just
to put that in context Indian diaspora
is one of the highest in any European
country so you would need Provisions
where there has to be some exchange now
when I go to the point about the
collaboration and so I started this just
as a small LinkedIn community that we
need to talk about AI we need to talk
about the technology between Germany and
India between between EU and India but
how can we facilitate that one point
which has been reflected in again in my
interaction has been that people are not
aware that how the data is being used by
the algorithms what what is going on
behind those computers or behind those
algorithms so what would be the factor
which would say that okay the data would
be used for this purpose for secondary
purpose but also going beyond that
purpose so that is something which
people people really fear about I coming
also a bit from the technology side I
think it's it's about the digital
literacy which should be provided to the
community or to the to the data who
whose data is being used that is
something which is very important and
that's where I see also the
collaboration between the two regions so
if you bring in the the the communities
or the patient stakeholders from India
or for example from Germany through
trusted partners for example through
through any University Hospitals or for
example let's say Tata trust within
India and you make them engage that this
is what the value we are trying to
provide by by providing this exchange
and that's where you get a starting
point and then you go to the next level
building either the the sandboxes or
building the framework that How would
how would the data exchange happen
within the regulatory environment of
India of EU and also in a way where this
data would be relevant for the future
techn technological development in
context of AI Quantum and all those
things which are coming by at least that
would be some of my thoughts to go into
that
direction right so um thanks uh jubin uh
we have a very young audience walking by
over there if you can notice that so I
ask for your patience uh with them uh
they are the future
of digitalization I hope um so we've
discussed a lot about data privacy and
data security and the question we come
back to again and again is this idea of
privacy versus the value that we can
derive from that data so what is the
tradeoff that we're willing to make how
private should we keep this data versus
you know are we forgoing some benefits
we can take out of you know letting it
be available for everyone so my um
question uh to that is in the future you
know so we have all the regulations in
place now but ultimately it boils down
to compliance it boils down to
individual companies insurers it boils
down to hospitals complying with the
directives around data privacy and data
regulation given to them by the state
right so if that doesn't happen then
there's no point in discussing what
regulations we want to have in place how
do you see that there is a compliance
problem at the moment or um these
organizations that actually are
responsible for deploying Healthcare are
unaware of these regulations or there's
no there's no incentive or disincentive
if they fail to comply or if they comply
with these things so do you see that as
um an issue and going forward in the
future do you think that's going to be a
challenge so maybe I start with karolina
if you want to
come I think I I started to think about
it and like you know just run a couple
of uh different cases in in my head
about the compliance think what we did
great in the you of course is the uh
gdpr and I think you refer in your
report to uh to that as the golden
standard as the data privacy and I don't
think we have any problem with
compliance I think we have a problem
with over compliance right so the often
the organizations and the companies uh
well of course we have the cases where
the companies and organizations got the
were fined so um but I think that there
were pretty like severe cases or pretty
obvious cases of some data bridge and
and data misuse while we have a problem
of the uh over compliance what I I mean
by this is often that we like also have
27 different um uh interpretations of
the gdpr in the EU so I I say that when
I'm in in
Finland I see that things are a bit more
relaxed there is a bit more well not
relaxed it's still we go by law right
things are done properly there is
consent and so on but at the same time
there is a bit more understanding in
that you know not everyone just wants to
steal your data it's like you know um
there is trust I think that the data
will be handled well while when I go to
and then when I'm in Finland I believe
that uh EHD are the European health data
space will actually happen then I want
go to Poland or even Germany and I'm
like oh my God like you know you cannot
really like even in you you cannot have
a name of people living in the apartment
building because it's not you know
according to the gdpr people go to the
doctors and doctors are afraid to open
the door and call People by names so
they call them by numbers or initials so
you know this kind of very like silly
example shows you how like people don't
really understand what is really there
in this regulation and they're afraid to
make an error so instead of just like
trying to understand what is the scope
and what is being allowed they just like
withdraw completely and I think that
this is something that we have to be
very careful about because this if we
then again we go with the with the data
space and we have we'll have again 27 or
any other regulation we have Digital
Data act and so on now if we will have
27 understandings of what this
regulation means then we are actually
getting into more trouble probably okay
thank you kolina so there is apparently
over compliance it's just the same
question of Are We over regulating
digital Health can stifling innovation
by doing that uh let me ask Nita um on
similar line so as we heard from kolina
in the EU you know we probably have a a
problem of over compliance in India
however do you think the situation is
different do you think there's a problem
of compliance because we're not at that
point yet where we can talk about over
compliance and I can give you uh sort of
an example that we have in the report
where we map The Guiding principles and
we uh in the nature of adoption
apparently the abdm framework enables
voluntary participation in the in this
digital health ecosystem and does not
mandate the key stakeholders to adopt
the framework whereas in the EU It Is by
virtue of being a regulation it is
mandatory so if it is not mandated how
do we ensure compliance
then yeah that that's that's a very
tricky question because initially when
it was announced that it is uh voluntary
I was like really you know you know this
will have impact on adoption but I think
then you fall back on what is the value
for it and I think if if it is not if it
is voluntary then it has to be backed by
a very strong reason which it should be
in any case whether voluntary or
non-voluntary that what is in it for me
to be compant so I think that is uh one
very important uh factor to uh
consider um I would just like to also
touch on this whole privacy issue
because I think because of these things
in
India um I think digital public
infrastructure is sort of a kind of
answer and I have to say that while I
started my journey designing you know
about this digital public infra which is
now abdm for health I had the
opportunity to actually work on uh in in
urban in in governance sector and here
I'm very happy to say that you know we
have actually built dpis we have
implemented them and we have seen the
results also right so um one of the
examples that all of you know of and I
think one of the principles of dpis is
privacy by Design so that uh you know
the whole compliance thing becomes
easier on people right so we all know
during the coid our vaccination
certificates right by the way they were
the first digital health record for
every Indian citizen that came as a
default right of of Co now this Co
certificate uh you know is basically it
was required because even though all the
attention was on you know creating the
vaccines their distribution to
facilities etc etc but how would we
prove that we have got vaccinations I
think this is a thinking we started
doing uh at eer and a community of you
know our leaders in Bangalore was that
we'll have to have a proof that you are
vaccinated so that it opens up lives and
livelihoods and I think sometime back
Carolina you mentioned that you know in
India everything has to be done at scale
well it has to be there is no other
option because if imagine dwalk which
which basically reach two billion it is
right now 2.5 but 2 billion 18 months
without a single glitch that was the
only way to make it successful right and
not kind of um you try to uh get your
certificate and it is buffering and you
know or or Rich have access to it and
poor don't have access to it now quickly
I want to bring to the point that when
we use this um uh this certificate a it
was uh acceptable in 120 countries so
again I'm talking of um movement of
digital health records you know from
India to other countries it was possible
and there is a lot of work that is
happening I think under wh probably to
make sure that how these uh digital
records can be exchanged and you know
the information and two privacy by
Design now when we give this record at
the airport right they looked at it
basically verified and it said yes or no
right if it is valid it said yes you
have been vaccinated and you will you
can travel but it did not take any of my
details my name my my contact number my
gender which is often uh you know the
one which is most abused I would say so
I think I just wanted to bring that
whole thing of privacy by Design uh I
think which is an important factor here
to make sure that the compliance is uh
uh thanks na I'm not sure if you guys
can hear uh naita clearly is you can
okay great um great so uh I think that's
an excellent point because for the
longest time I've been wondering if
there is a possibility if we will ever
be able to exchange health data between
the two jurisdictions but the fact that
we've already done that during coid when
we moved around with our vaccine
certificates says that you know if it's
a global problem we are able to do that
so I think there is some scope um uh in
that in that area um Kesh what do you
think about the compliance issue because
you know it's it's our report in a way
and you've been sort of the primary uh
writer of the report so what do you
think about the compliance problem
um thank you so much Ma for that
question that's very um important
question at least for the India sake
because like we are just going into
compliance with the new you know the
data protection bill you know enacted so
here I have like two points to make and
it's more on the levels of like the
perception level aspect which I think
like kolina also pointed out um you know
during the resistance to change first
let me come towards the supply side
which is like you know your data
fiduciaries which is the data control
ERS in India so I guess like you know
the one way to look at this like the
voluntary aspect itself is that is like
how can we actually move this maybe long
term but like you know one thing that
we've also looked into the report is
like how can we move Beyond like looking
this um you know the Privacy as an
element of compliance and like also
seeing that as a value proposition so
how can we make that as a competitive
element for like you know the you know
Supply s such that they they don't
really have to like see this as
something as a burden rather like move
towards like you know doing it on
themselves because in long term there
can be some you know um positive
implications to themselves in terms of
like trust building and Etc and stuff
where like some of the popular companies
have already done that so that's the you
know important piece that comes at the
supply side and the compliance being you
know also like I wanted to like little
bit touch upon the point on the data
protection itself right like the
tradeoff thing that mujah you mentioned
so I think like again here I guess like
you know one aspect that as we are just
going moving towards like you know
having a legislation though we have the
right for a long time now like couple of
years now but right to privacy but I
think it's very important we take the
image and the perception behind data
protection clearly out there in terms of
data protection doesn't really mean that
like you know you shouldn't share your
data it means like you know share your
data you know appropriately for the
purpose for which it is so I guess like
you know that message is very much
important and I guess that's also one of
the key learnings that we could like
pull out from eu's experience itself
right like you know one of some of the
experts also mentioned that just because
there has been like a lot of laws and
like you know no flexibilities and
rigidities within the law which garalina
also mentioned people are also like very
much acclimatized to this idea of like
you know sticking with that and like you
know thinking that oh if we move Beyond
of this that means we are trading of
privacy so I guess like that message has
to be put out very clearly when it comes
to demand side in terms of data
protection really means is like you know
um sharing data appropriately when
there's a prote and that for the purpose
so U yeah I'll stop
there great um thank you so much uh we
are almost at the end of our discussion
um but um I do want to um you know kind
of uh go over uh the buzzword um these
days which is of course AI so um um
everybody talks about AI nobody can stop
talking about AI um just recently there
was the AI safety Summit as well that
happened um you know where I think lot
of discussions at a policy level
happened around the safe the dangers and
the ethical usage of AI um in just the
last you know we have maybe a couple of
more minutes um but um rapid fire you
know 30 340 seconds each panelist um
would love to hear your perspective on
you know the use of AI in healthcare um
where are we headed with it and what's
the scope and dangers um 30 seconds
maybe we'll start with jubin yeah thanks
Paul maybe before that I I again wanted
to mention about compliance I think the
the aspect we see here also is you see a
lot of data flowing around across and
then you have sometimes breaches in
between and that's how also the the
compliance Works where you have some
breaches where the the data or the the
Technologies which are not compliant
come in to the point about the AI I
think it it would be a tool which would
be there for the future I think it's
it's something which we realized later
at in the point of evolution itself and
I personally believe it would shape how
how Humanity would evolve but it would
not lead to Extinction which is how it's
made out to be in terms of the health
care itself I personally believe and
this is something which I see across the
community itself that it would be
something which will complement the
capacities of the doctors or the healthc
Care staff and help them to perform
their duties better and finally benefit
the health outcomes itself I think that
the people who would be left out would
be the people who are scared or who are
not looking to adapt to the technology
and there they would lag in making their
interventions or providing the outcomes
to to the to the Final End user which is
again the patients and again from the
patient side I think it's important that
it's important for them to understand
that how AI would impact or what
algorithms are being used how it would
be processed not in the the literal
sense but at least in the in a basic
science sense I think that's something
which is important and relevant in down
the line at least for a decade excellent
excellent so uh yes for AI from jubin uh
um you know I think from a patient
perspective we need more awareness of
how that works you know and I think
there's a lot of potential for you know
Bridging the Gap with you know um
diagnosis and supporting doctors and um
the healthcare system as a whole um over
to you Carolina I only a second what
what youve been said and then expanded
that then this also means like embracing
or bring maybe one one thing about the
benefits of AI of course we see for
example this in Radiology right like
reading the the the results like better
than and a doctor could do but this also
means that brings us back to the
availability of the data we have to
train the models that brings us also to
the issue of Regulation here I would say
that we don't we better don't under
regulate we really what EU is doing with
the EU AI regulation I think it's a
great thing and and and should be
supported that we actually are able to
understand what's the model what's the
what's the system how it works um
because actually people's life are at
stake so it's not even about stealing
data or using data or misusing but
really like people's life are at stake
um so yeah I think those two two things
are um definitely matter and skills of
course like also skills of patients but
also doctors and this also means we will
have new uh occupations we will have new
jobs you have to bring to the hospital
people who don't do anything medical
they deal with data they deal with the
AI and you have to also bring them as
part of the Health Care system so again
breaking silos this is a new skill from
uh needed from everyone yeah no
absolutely I think great points um you
know uh uh we can uh maybe even expect a
human doctor to perhaps make mistakes
but an AI cannot make a mistake because
lives are at stake of course um naita
over to
you um I think quite much has been
covered by my fellow panelists but um
and I definitely had written out here on
the training data sets for AI because I
think that is very important uh it's
garbage in garbage out it's like you
know the analogy that I give here is you
know recipes sometimes you pick European
um American recipes and I you know I
made a note for myself that when they
say put one egg I use at least two to
three eggs because in India the eggs
size is much smaller right so it is it
is very contextual I think you have to
understand what it is what is for a
white male you know all these parameters
Etc they don't apply to um A different
race right so I think that importance
has has to be given to uh the training
data sets and I think the second point I
want to make is basically regulation
follows technology and it is bit too far
it has a lot of catch up to do and I
just hope that um you know somehow
regulation is able to keep up to Pace
with technology and not go too far
behind because that's when all these
problems occur yeah excellent point um
you know um emphasis again on the
regulation and the need for you know the
pace um at which the policy and
regulations evolve um with you know the
technological advances um last um kamesh
uh you know we've worked a lot on the
report you know we've looked at so many
aspects of you know digitization
interoperability security privacy I know
we have also touched a bit about AI in
the report but um you know your quick um
perspective on this um quickly P here
like two points that I wanted to make
like again resonates with whatever we
discuss like you know just like you know
we keep talking about AI regulations
like you know what are we really mean by
AI regulation has to be fleshed out
because like I guess like when we really
talk about like you know Healthcare
within utilization of AI the ecosystem
has various players within inter which
starts from your air developers then
your a deployers your hospitals and or
they have you know healthare facilities
then the doctors themselves the users
who actually like you know technically
use it so I guess like understanding
that there are like various you know
individuals and various stakeholders
present within this ecosystem and like
looking mapping the liability
accordingly will be very very essential
as we move forward in terms of like
making the you know like entirely the AI
responsible the second point that I
quickly wanted to you know come up is
that um
is basically on like the regulation
aspect itself right like in terms of
like you know this is one of the things
that we looked into the report also in
terms of the consent artifact giving
that an example right like you know how
the concern artifact can actually like
apply in a situation like you know
artificial intelligence Solutions is
like going to be very difficult so I
think like you know there has to be some
level of like you know understanding in
terms of like how our regulations should
evolve in terms of like in tandem with
like the evolution of the technology
itself such that we can make it secure
and like it doesn't become like a burden
for us to like you know follow something
which is there already so yeah thank you
excellent thank you thank you so much
kames um maybe that uh could be our next
research uh topic which is really around
you know collaboration and exploring um
AI in healthare and the regulations
around it um I think we are at the end
of our panel thank you to the panelist
uh we have a couple of qu minutes more
so you know open to any questions from
the audience uh yeah I think we have a
few more minutes y
please think we need
m
hi great panel everyone um my name is
tushi I'm a public policy student at the
her school a student of mujahid um my
question is more on your statement that
that you're a fan of
collaboration um so I would really like
to know because we highlighted what sort
of differences and priorities are there
in case of India in the case of EU so
how in what sense like how do you Vision
collaboration in What fields in what
sectors in what ways and also how can we
incorporate these differences um in for
in for the
collaboration yeah is it for me uh
anyone anyone it's okay yeah maybe I I
just a quick thought on that I think
collaboration is essential the point is
you make make the stakeholders realize
how I would I would personally recommend
and I definitely Advocate is have strong
working groups have trusted
organizations get involved in this
discussion also make understand at at
the regulatory level that health is not
just essential part of life it's
security of life and it's security of a
country and if you put that in
perspective you would definitely get
collaboration so have strong working
groups have trusted
organizations provide flexibility for
smaller startups to work at at the
flexible level across two countries
become part of the system leverage data
provide Solutions see what are the
outcomes and have some quick outcomes on
that I think those are some immediate
starting points definitely you need a a
agile approach also from a regulatory
aspect that okay if there are some
changes happening here we would be open
to having this a bit quicker or agile
approach also at the regulation side I
think if you go about in those Direction
you'll definitely see a lot more
collaboration and and potentially good
outcomes would anyone else like to add I
also immediately think about of course
this collaboration exchange and learning
from each other and I think about the
issue of those reverse innovations that
we also often think from I think
European perspective that we have to go
to India it's a big market so we have to
sell there right that's the opportunity
or then use the uh it Specialists from
India for the sake of our companies here
but then to think that if we if there is
also an innovation developed in India
and the I don't know low resource
setting and it works there it can also
work in so many different settings in in
in this part of the world and it might
be 10 or 100 times cheaper so we
actually again have to be curious and
and learn and see what's going on there
instead of having a bit of this mindset
that oh it's a big Market we will sell
uh our our Innovations there great
thanks uh kolina maybe one last Quick uh
comment or
yeah hello my name is Anisha I'm a first
year MPP student and I'm also uh
following Health Pro uh Health policy
track um my question is um in healthcare
sector we are talking a lot about
digitalization which I think mostly is
to the realm of administration of Health
rather than the human aspect of
healthare many of the global problems
like polio or child mortality were dealt
with Community healthare providers not
by uh digital interventions maybe in the
administrative aspect of
digitalization can help in healthcare
but we must not forget the human aspect
of healthcare the doctors the Asha
workers when it comes to India in
Bangladesh and EOP IA most of the health
issues were deal dealt by community
healthcare workers and I feel uh human
aspect should not be overlooked when we
talk about digital digitalization and I
want your opinion on those aspect thank
you thank you uh maybe Nita you want to
add something real quick on that yeah so
I think that's a great Point Anisha you
made and we kind of started with that
our conversation so all these are public
delivery services right which basically
needs an intermediary
to deliver that service to you and this
is the layer that we actually apart from
being customer Centric or patient
Centric I think this is one layer which
needs attention uh for adoption of
digital Health it is very important that
it is easy to operate so I just want to
say at eov where we are looking at
digital health on campaigns in Africa we
have just launched a product and I think
the feedback that has come back from the
ground is it is simple and I think that
we feel will go a long way because if it
is intuitive right uh people at the
front line often are not that educated
right so if if they say this is simple
to operate I think you have one half the
battle thank you very much so thank you
so we are just uh in time to finish uh
so my big takeaway from this uh session
today is that technology may be the tool
that we need but really collaboration
and knowledge sharing is the fuel that
we need to run that engine uh so thank
you very much to all the panelists today
and the participants can we have a round
of applause for everyone today thank
you um lovely meeting you
here I think it a good session yeah I
mean I think the only problem is uh you
have to put things in in a very short
pressy you know sort of a thing
but it it'll be good to have some long
form discussions you know discussions I
definitely agree I had to squeeze my
presentation also very quickly there so
much to like talk about this topic would
love to like meet you also naita and
like you know once the report out would
love to like you know come and like you
know present it to you and your team has
well so topic you're working on and I
think youve rightly pointed out on data
protection and the security I think that
is something we can definitely we should
learn from
EU because they spend lot of time on
regulations and
legislation you know than on technology
whereas we go first with technology and
then it kind of you know takes these
crops up like later yeah EX
follow even without and all that so I
think that that that's the issue but
it's a serious one and I think similarly
for U you know for EU is really this
whole DPI approach obviously G20 has
done enough you don't need to see
anymore but um but I think at eager so
now I'm the eager
foundation and um you know we are doing
a lot of work on dpis in urban
government